I know who you are you're the attorney
whose family they killed her nothing my
father
and truth
and now you hunt them
adios
[Music]
there's proof the cartel helped the
terrorists get to the porter depressants
adding drug cartels to the list of
terrorist organizations you can
understand how that will expand our
ability to combat them you want to see
this thing through I'm gonna have to get
dirty dirty is exactly why you're here
you're gonna help us start a war with
hope everyone no rules this time
your objective was start a war between
the Mexican cartels
not with the Mexican government
this girl was witness to the admission
correct yes sir
we can't risk her falling into the wrong
hands clean the scene I want me to cut
ties you gotta get rid of her I can't do
that don't put me in that situation you
got to do what you got to do I'm gonna
need a strike team to the Blackhawks
drone for the TAC capability or is it
[ __ ] max occur
[Music]
you have no reason to trust me
which trusted me I saw you go survive
good luck luck doesn't move on the side
of the border
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
very potent it is wonderful to see you
yesterday's isn't it
[Music]
it was called an emergency meeting this
weekend I promised my wife and daughter
I'd take them away this weekend sir we
need to cut 20% Lee you're promised
these people good jobs that I thought
you'd do anything for this company I'll
have a good time
[Music]
[Music]
what to do what to do what to do
what to do indeed
[Music]
Pooh Christopher Robin
[Music]
I don't see any cracks a few wrinkles
maybe
[Music]
my pants actually that may have been Oh
you're living the dreams DP yeah strong
beautiful girlfriend
sorry I'm late I was rounding up all the
gluten in the world and launching in
space where it can't not hurt us ever
again
kiss me like you missed me red what in
the [ __ ] sickle is this
my name's cable I'm here for the kid
what the kid mover guy
kids give us a chance to be better than
we used to be you need you you're a lot
smarter than I look i'ii let cable kill
this kid but i can't do this alone
did you speak up it's hard to hear you
with that pity dick in your mouth we're
gonna form a super duper [ __ ] group
we need them topping morally flexible
and young enough to carry their own
franchise for 10 to 12 years known as
x-force isn't that a little derivative
you're absolutely right now let's go get
our [ __ ] on don't call it a comeback
tell me they got that in slow motion you
and the right thing is messy you want to
fight for what's right sometimes you
have to fight dirty
that is why Sisterhood of the Traveling
Pants is pure pornography oh god I wish
I finished college it lives up to the
hype plus plus darken they probably
won't even make it three yeah why would
they stop it - you killed it
[Music]
I have some questions for you professor
this is a surprise there's a rumor that
Newt Scamander is headed to Paris
I know he's working under your boobs
what do you have to say for yourself
Dumbledore
if you'd ever had the pleasure to teach
him you'd know new is not a great
follower of orders the times coming
[Music]
when you were gonna have to pick a side
[Music]
are you going somewhere no way guys away
Jesus
[Music]
I can't move against Grindelwald
it has to be you
[Music]
blessing me bother thrice in okay what
do you want money
where do you want but I have a very poor
choice of words
by a mr. Franklin I have an offer I want
you to kill someone for me
[Music]
black briefcase in a locker that is a
job for mr. Franklin this is massive now
train till tomorrow
404 going all the store affords an age
away it's not time that I'm trying to
kill one likewise not really
just any
I'll set them on one another like
starving rats in a cage and you can
watch through the bars bang for
information might be a filthy lap dogs
about and get ones he always is read
pretty much yeah follow me it's down the
rabbit hole
who says mr. ezel a star hey what's
wrong with you I'm in our 24 blood lust
[Music]
to imminent death
[Music]
come back again soon hands
don't bring him
[Music]
Wow illumination
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
your bad banana with her
[Music]
today we will do mean things and we will
do them in style are you getting that
[Music]
the bridge
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello your Lewis I presume you'll see
things are quite different here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the house is a very old place
there's a clock in the walls we don't
know what it does except
something horrible
so you've told Luis everything well not
everything
[Music]
[Music]
have a look around you're perfectly safe
that's safe as long as it's fed
[Music]
[Music]
do you know how to drive a stick I'm so
sorry you know how to change it here
what's idea
[Music]
okay
we just want to talk about your
boyfriend but he dumped me juicy I I'm
sorry what some bad people are after me
the other after you I don't know could
you dated the spy
I find up
it's a flashdrive you have to swallow it
before they come back there is no
turning back
we're semi-professionals at this point
professional we are professional
[Music]
I asked if I don't like this I'll tell
you anything you wanna know I've never
kept a secret in my life
Audrey shaves between her boobs Morgan
flosses with her hair just extremes
about minions just the one minion with
the one eye she googled it on my
computer and now I get a lot of weird
ads the entire time I knew him he only
ever had one call
to wipe out half the universe if he gets
all the Infinity stones she can do it
with the snap of his fingers just like
that tell me his name again
Santos
[Music]
we got one advantage
he's coming to us
we have a dance once so that's what we
use
[Music]
let's talk about this plan ears I think
it's good except it sucks so let me do
the plan and that way it might be really
good
Wow
the end is near
and um
half of humanity will still exist
perfectly balanced
as all things should be
I hope that remember you
[Music]
I'm Peter by the way dr. strange
oh you're using your made-up names then
I am spider-man
[Music]